hallo liebe freunde von truck tv dies
ist eine video antwort für den kanal
klicks um klicks um ist der kanal der
die prominenten auf youtube oder aus dem
fernsehen interviewt und meine frage
heute in klicks um ist die frage an kari
kari du hast damals bei bei dem kanal
sind groß gemacht harry potter und so
weiter glaube ich war dass die videos
wurden gesperrt ein kanal war sogar
kurzzeitig gesperrt und deshalb wollte
ich wissen kamen außer der videospiele
noch irgendwas finanzielles negativ ist
auch dazu da haben sie das einfach dabei
belassen
vielen dank für die antwort
mach's gut du hast vielleicht mal
irgendwas über mich gelesen du hast die
wikipedia seite von mir angeguckt und
meine filme von meinem buch was ich
gerade neu herausgebracht hat ja also
erstmal zu beantworten nein ich hatte
keine finanziellen schwierigkeiten und
wenn dann hätte ich das wahrscheinlich
auch schon irgendwo gesagt und immer
noch weiter gesagt jetzt warner brothers
aber es ist einfach wirklich es ist
nichts passiert und das war sind youtube
richtlinien und ich finde mich damit ab
aber ich würde nicht verklagt oder
überhaupt eine unterhaltungs oder
unterlassen und ja also
dass nichts passiert keine sorge